the one thing that I've never been able
to like understand of like how how your
brain is just this powerful we're going
into some shower thoughts all right
we're not gonna we're going to shower
thoughts now okay like split
personalities yeah that like that like
how how does how is your brain [ __ ]
capable of that okay so that is that is
insane to me it's because it's true
well I think a lot of the time stuff
like trauma can cause that right yeah
it's like it's like a defense it's like
an internal defense for some people for
others it's not but like there's a many
reasons why you're you're brain anatomy
or whatever could have the decision that
this is how you're going to deal with it
or this is what's going to happen yeah
right yeah it's like it's a defense
mechanism the way I always try to like
explain to people if if this ever
conversation never comes up which it
really does but like for example
one thing that weep as humans believe
without a doubt is that when I've seen
something I saw it yes like I 100 saw
this you can't change my mind right and
it's like well no because we have we
have many many occasions where like
witness testimony where they swear they
saw it and they swear on their life and
it's been not not maliciously because
they had no reason to lie and it was
just wrong like it just did not happen
it did not align so like
like the brain memories perception it's
all like almost it changes at times I
mean that's like if your memories can't
be trusted as being fact yeah and and
what you saw like who knows what else to
[ __ ] your brain is making out oh yeah
and I mean you know that's like the
whole basis on like sleight of hand
magic for example it's like your brain
immediately thinks oh that card
disappeared yeah but no it's just your
brain just can't keep up with it it's
like our brain is like an algorithm that
has chosen the best way to do things
yeah you know I actually have a theory
okay going on a slight hand I'm not a
scientist none of us are sorry guys this
is my theory and of understanding of
stuff I've seen yeah okay so I I have a
theory so you you guys have all felt
Deja Vu right yes of course yes yeah
everyone everyone felt deja vu in one
sense or form even if they've never been
to a place or been in a situation I've
been in this place before yeah I have
been through this place before
so like I have a theory that Deja Vu
comes from like you experiencing
basically the same thing in your
imagination maybe through dreams or
something like that because like
possible yeah yeah because I when they
say that you remember all of your dreams
I'm like how that's that's [ __ ] I
remember none of my dreams but I I
believe like some people will say that
yeah you remember all of your dreams
even if you can't recall them and I have
a theory that Deja Vu is your
subconscious brain being like I have
seen this before in my memory somewhere
yeah yeah and come back in 300 years to
find out yeah
have you ever felt jamaivu before what
the [ __ ] is that it's the opposite of
deja vu that sounds like a dance move
what were you experiencing you're like
I've never experienced it I've never
experienced something before and but you
have
that's the real thing what have you had
what happened I've never experienced
well we're just asking
because it's a thing I don't know I'm
pretty sure like Alzheimer's right
just describe Outsiders
that's just a fancy word for outside
for myself
that's just Memento yeah I think our
brains are computers in a way they're
very very good computers and yeah
computers you know what's my favorite
show about the brain the brain named
itself
nope it's not worth it
[Music]
well like one of the freakiest videos
I've ever seen which I still [ __ ] if
if I want to go to into like an
existential crisis and I watch this
video it's like a cpg gray video called
like there are two of you or something
like that okay where he explains that
you know there's the right side of your
brain and then there's the left side of
your brain yeah right
and uh
so that's connected Vera nerve but there
have been cases in medical history where
they've had to like disconnect the nerve
connecting the right and left side of
the brain yeah
um and you can still function as a human
being right right but
only I think once one of the side of
your brain is like is in charge of
speech right yeah yeah and the other is
like part of like motor skills and stuff
like that right yeah I mean yeah I
believe that one side uh if I remember
this correctly one side of your brain
controls one side of it and the other
one controls the other side of it yeah
so there have been cases where you've
had the split brain
and uh they've given like an apple to
let's say the rights uh they've they've
put like the right
I'm going to take a toilet break and
then I'm going to watch the video and
then I'm going to explain it because
that's too easy and that's too simple
here's the problem with the brain right
so every explanation you have for it is
not who don't even [ __ ] know what's
happening we don't know what's happening
it's way way complicated more than we
could ever imagine yes it's the brain
trying to understand the brain exactly
it's too much we don't know what the
brain is so when people are like oh left
side rocho make one personality one good
it's like no that's oh that's it we'll
pack it in there thank you so much thank
you so much for that
oh okay thanks so we know when to stop
the sign and stop wasting all the money
don't research anymore it's the brain
trying to convince itself on how it
works we like easy answers because we're
humans and it doesn't [ __ ] work like
that no of course not and that's why
like study is still being done but like
I think you know with modern technology
we are getting a much better officer
yeah I mean we can take educated I
reckon one like surface level at this
point in time it's like understanding
how the brain works all right tell me
about the [ __ ] left and right side
and why you're wrong all right
why I'm wrong okay wrong predisposition
Conor's brain is like I don't believe
any of this this is [ __ ] brain is a
lie he's lying he's lying come on my
brain is like don't trust that brain all
right that brain is full of [ __ ] Connor
all right so there have been cases where
for medical reasons uh they've split the
left and right side of the brain so
they've split any kind of connection
between the left and right and the right
side of the brain yeah but your left and
right side of the brain is in charge of
different things so there have been
cases where it feels like to a patient
of one of these conditions that the like
they would make her they would try to
pick something and then their other hand
would kind of like disagree with them
they they noticed some disagreement with
disagreement with that right and so they
they have done some tests right where
they say they give a command to let's
say the left side of the brain this love
division give a command to the left side
of the brain like pick up a Rubik's Cube
and they show nothing to the right side
of the brain right and they ask them
okay did you pick up an object and the
the guy answers because only once side
is in charge of speech no didn't pick up
anything and then so they give the
instruction for like the left side to
put the Rubik's Cube on the right side
and the scary thing is that
because one side is in charge of
reasoning they'll just like make up a
reason that that a cube has just
suddenly appeared in their hand they'll
let they'll they'll reason that
something like oh I've just always
wanted to solve a Rubik's Cube or
something like that and that is like
terrifying yeah I believe that this
experiment could have taken place and
could have happened I just don't buy
into the whole the right and left side
thing and I mean it seems to I mean
that's your right side of your brain
that's your reasoning logic side
operation
I also Googled it because I'm pretty
sure I heard this was a myth one time
and then yeah I Googled it and
apparently this is also there is some
very very very very slight truth to have
different areas of the brain work but
it's not that easy where it's just left
and right obviously if you start cutting
the brain up weird shit's gonna happen
yeah like the dude who had a whole
[ __ ] pipe rammed through his brain
and survived yeah who started being way
more Angry like when you take out uh the
is it the frontal frontal cortex other
cortex yeah I think you people start
acting way more Angry yeah get way more
uh I guess what's the word isn't that
like your reason and logic side of your
brain yeah I mean you okay from what I
understand you can't just like cut the
same thing out of every single brain and
the same results are going to happen
like it's like if you saw there are some
parts though like the amygdala for
example which is like the part of your
brain that operates emotions right if
you cut that out of any person then
maybe not all of your emotions are going
to dispute you're not going to turn into
like a [ __ ] it's caught up a butt
like a lot of emotions is controlled by
that part of your brain so if you cut it
out then you'll definitely be less
emotive oh I just thought they were
called kudaris yeah kudres are just
people
I don't know I think even remotely
pretending like we understand one tenth
of brain science
I took psychology one in college
tries to attempt to be to be brain
Science
question of like what are you you know
can you bring this topic up if none of
us know [ __ ] anything about it are we
allowed to talk well we can yeah we can
make speculations I'm betting the
brain's gonna [ __ ] end tomorrow
speculating well it's like not if if not
even [ __ ] you know professional
scientists who work on this kind of [ __ ]
day in and day out fully understand
what's going on then I think that leaves
enough Liberty for people of no idea to
talk about it as well also like because
it's like talking about this amazing oh
is that like a bad I don't know well I
don't know like I feel like that
argument again I feel like that argument
is used to discredit scientists I hate
that argument no but of course but like
what we are talking about in this
episode isn't going to hurt someone no
no like someone's not you know no one
watching this is going to be like oh
[ __ ] I already feel like frontal lobe
I'm feeling too many things
I mean it's [ __ ] insane that at one
point you know a lobotomies existed I
just I just find that insane you know
how that was just like a treat is there
any times where it's still used not no
no no no
I hope I really hope not I think they
very quickly realized that you are just
basically killing someone yeah
inadvertently but like I I mean I mean
it's the equivalent of when you have an
old CRT and you just start hitting it on
the side so they can operate again take
out your brain and have a brain
transplant yeah yeah you know your brain
is [ __ ] for some reason yeah
keep you alive you know whatever and
then they put a new brain in I don't
know they can't do that I'm pretty sure
but um
brain transplant it's possible for some
reason we can keep you alive we can give
you a new brain yeah yeah are you still
you no
no no he just you just described the
[ __ ] plot of ghosts in the show
literally right for what yeah it's like
if you if your soul is inside of an
Android is that Android really is your
soul in your brain
s
now we're getting it's like the
religious terrorists [ __ ] what's that I
love that [ __ ] what's the name of
that thing go on go on say a thing he's
gonna bring up a meme
so like Uganda Knuckles
[Laughter]
uh uh thesis oh yeah where you replace
everything right right right yeah do you
want to explain what the ship of thesis
is for people yes so obviously there's
this this question that is arised where
if you start with a ship let's say
you're getting a long Voyage from the UK
to America [ __ ] knows how long back then
yeah and every now and then while your
ship is going along this route you know
a plank of wood snaps off here you maybe
you change some word here you found
after doing this whole journey that your
entire ship has sort of changed nearly
all of its parts and the ship is kind of
a little bit different and it's not the
same ship but it's still called the ship
of thesis yeah is it is it still the
same ship even if you change every part
over time well technically speaking if
we're getting into shower thoughts
humans are also that way because it's
like we're constantly reproducing cells
in our body cells die and then we make
new cells to replace those older you
know you replace your skeleton as well
right yeah yeah so here's the question
you knew that I didn't yeah yeah yeah so
you you there is a point where you
literally replace every cell in your
body yeah you replace every cell in your
body right so basically us now there is
not a single cell in our body right now
that is the same cells that we had when
we were why am I getting thank God beta
cells
right now they're replacing my good
shells with shittier old cells stop it's
not making me old no but here's the
thing right here's another shower
thought newer cells are still making you
older how does that work because they're
copying it themselves Joey they're just
copying over and over again okay but are
you the same person that you are as a
baby if all of the cells that you had as
a baby are now non-existent in your body
because they've been replaced with newer
cells you're not the same performance
right huh it's all mitosis what what's
mitosis cells duplicating oh okay okay
yeah but they're duplicating
McDonald's to the mix that would have
been fine if I gave them what they
wanted but no I had to bring a Big Mac
and many milkshakes and then the cells
started [ __ ] duplicating like crazy
start [ __ ] dying